so schnell nicht so einzelplan der
letzte an diesem zweiten sitzungstag zu
den haushaltsberatungen das wird er sein
also plan 23 für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung die
zuständige ministerin heißt das wenn ja
schulze die erwarten wir gleich den
auftakt macht aber jetzt als erster
redner kasten körper für die union
in diesen dramatischen zeiten bewegt
sich das bmz im stürmischen vor wasser
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit hat
regelmäßig direkte auswirkungen auf die
menschen in den krisengeschüttelten
ländern und regionen dieser welt um es
einmal in aller klarheit zu sagen
unsere hilfe kann für den empfänger und
wir gehören schnell nach washington zur
pressekonferenz von anthony blinkende
us-außenminister liebe frau ministerin
ihre reise nach kiew dieser tage zeigt
dass sie bereit sind sich für ihre sache
einzusetzen
wichtig ist aber auch dass man sein haus
hinter sich weiß dass man weiß dass die
eigenen leute einem folgen und dass die
mitarbeiter auch willens sind politische
vorgaben umzusetzen und die dinge
möglich zu machen und nicht gute ideen
und ehrliche einsatzbereitschaft durch
kleinteilige auslegung von
verwaltungsvorschriften im keim zu
ersticken
dazu ein kleines beispiel
ich habe mich dieser tage im rheinland
mit einem verein getroffen der seit
jahren in asien aktiv ist sehr feine
beeindruckende engagiere leute mit guten
ideen
wer aber von einem solchen privaten
verein im gegenzug für eine fördersumme
von gerade einmal 4000 euro zum aufbau
eines kindergartens derart viele
verwendungsnachweise berichte und
formulare absurde dass am ende des tages
mehrere ein ordner gefüllt werden der
wirkt privates engagement ab der verein
will in zukunft nichts mehr mit dem bmz
machen sondern nur noch über spenden das
bedauere ich aber das verstehe ich auch
und ja ich höre den zwischenruf das ist
nicht erst in den letzten wochen so
gewesen und trotzdem weiter eine
realität und deshalb bin ich gezwungen
hier darauf einzugehen denn ich kenne
das bmz ja schon eine ganze weile und
ich bin überzeugt dass es dort auch
gelegentlich am zielorientierten denken
fehlt
wäre ein berichterstatter selbst der
regierungskoalition kommt mit einer
eigenen idee oder einem eigenen projekt
vorschlag um die ecke da läuft der
verwaltungsapparat des bmz auf
hochtouren und regelmäßig leidet lautet
sein leider das ergebnis das projekt das
projekt ist wirklich richtig toll aber
leider leider gibt es dazu keine
passende verwaltungsvorschrift der
wiederaufbau des hafens in bayreuth
beirut wäre ein weiteres stichwort
welches dem geneigten kenner des bmz mit
eigenen einiger irritation zurücklässt
also viel geld im einzelplan zu haben
ist das eine wirklich etwas daraus zu
machen ist das andere
und ich wünsche ihnen liebe frau
ministerin ganz ehrlich und aufrichtig
dass sie in der lage sind dass sie die
kraft haben dieses haus in dem geiste zu
führen das ist kultur wird dass man den
mut hatten den mut entwickelt auch mal
neue wege zu gehen neue pfade
einzuschlagen dinge möglich zu machen
und nicht zu verhindern der etat des bmz
ist in diesem jahr bei einer rekord
summe von ca 13,3 milliarden euro an
gelangt das ist in der derzeitigen lage
das ist der derzeitigen lage in der welt
geschuldet das war aber nicht der
verdienst der bundesregierung nein es
brauchte erst in den
haushaltsverhandlungen
das engagement der koalitions
berichterstatter um hier die dringend
erforderlichen akzente zu setzen in
afrika droht die grösste ernährungs
katastrophe seit jahrzehnten
und was macht die bundesregierung sie
streicht dem
un-welternährungsprogramm 20 millionen
die arme aus selber haben dann zu guter
letzt den etatansatz und 42 millionen
gestärkt ein erster entscheidender
schritt um nur ein beispiel aus den
verhandlungen zu nennen so wurde erst in
der bereinigungssitzung verhindert dass
deutschland hier versagt und seine
internationale verantwortung missachtet
aber sie an ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der ampel auch die
weitsicht der ampel berichterstatter
wurde leider nicht überall gepflegt so
hatte die un organisation für
industrielle entwicklung unido unter
ihrem neuen generaldirektor gerd müller
um eine vergleichsweise bescheidene
mittel erhöhung für ihren kernhaushalt
gebeten insgesamt handelt sich schauen 3
millionen euro müller immerhin unser
ehemaliger minister im bmz will unido
grundlegend informieren
reformieren und auch von negativen
chinesischen einfluss befreien müller
hat sich auch inhaltlich viel
vorgenommen stichwort
technologiekooperation beim thema
klimaschutz kooperation kein thema
wasserstoff das wäre doch in unserem
ureigensten interesse ihn hier zu
unterstützen was du die ampel nichts die
rest ihn hängen
insgesamt so mein eindruck haben die
berichterstatter der ampel mit den
haushaltsberatungen
mutlos und unambitioniert agiert so als
begriffen sie sich als sachwalter der
ministerien das aber liebe freunde und
freude das ist nicht sache und aufgabe
der ausfälle hier geht es um kontrolle
und nicht um applaus erlauben sie mir
bitte eine bemerkung zum schluss in den
letzten jahren haben sich die
einzelpläne des auswärtigen amtes und
des bmz mehr als verdoppelt insgesamt
haben beide häuser zusammen bereits mehr
als 20 milliarden euro aber die
bundesregierung ist leider bis heute
nicht in der lage zeitnah mitzuteilen
welche ressorts zb in unserem
reformpartner land ghana mit welchen
programmen und mit welchen partnern mit
welchen geldern unterwegs sind und das
gilt leider nicht nur für ghana sondern
auch für alle übrigen länder das ist
schlicht und ergreifend ein unding und
ich glaube wir sollten wir uns
fraktionsübergreifend einig sind das
abzustellen bereits 2020 damals die
große koalition hat dem bmz personal zum
aufbau einer länder datenbank bewilligt
diese sollte auf knopfdruck diese
informationen bereitstellen wo fördert
deutschland in der welt welche projekte
neulich habe ich nachgefragt im bmz wie
es denn so läuft in sachen datenbank
nicht habe eine wird reiche antwort
erhalten vielleicht gibt es im dritten
quartal ein neues transparenz portal das
war nicht so verheißungsvoll das
auswärtige amt hingegen hat sich willens
gezeigt wenn es solche datenbank in
kürzester zeit auf die beine zu stellen
mein eindruck in den verhandlungen war
dass die koalitions berichterstatter zum
auswärtigen amt gleichfalls willens
waren hier was zu bewegen wir als
opposition hätten dabei rat parat
gestanden denn unter blieb leider ein
solcher beschluss der geneigte
beobachter können natürlich jetzt
spekulieren woran es denn gelegen hat
aber das nützt alles nicht uns allen
geht es sich um die sache das thema ist
dafür zu wichtig deshalb mein wunsch auf
mehr ampelkoalition ehren weitblick in
den beratungen zum 23er haushalten
vielen dank
und für die bundesregierung hat das wort
die bundesministerin svenja schulze
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der 24 februar
markiert eine zäsur in der deutschen
sicherheitspolitik das haben die
heutigen debatten hier noch mal sehr
sehr verdeutlicht und ich sage
ausdrücklich auch ich als
entwicklungsministerin unterstütze das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr viele
haben gehofft auch ich dass wir
schrittweise in eine weltordnung kommen
die konflikte ohne waffen lösen kann
aber putins brutaler angriffskrieg hat
diese hoffnung zerstört
militärische fähigkeiten sind notwendig
aber sie alleine führen uns nicht in
eine friedliche welt mehr noch sie
dürfen nicht das erste mittel der wahl
sein weder in unserem handeln noch in
unseren köpfen
neben den täglich sich überschlagenden
ruf nach schweren waffen müssen wir
gemeinsam auch wieder unsere stimme für
nichtmilitärische wege zur
konfliktbewältigung und vor allen dingen
für konfliktprävention erheben und dafür
braucht es eine starke
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
zusammenarbeit die ungleichheit die
hunger die armut als treiber von
konflikten bekämpft die bildung die
gesundheit die zivilgesellschaftliche
kräfte und demokratieentwicklung stärkt
und das ist es was eine friedliche welt
von morgen braucht und deshalb setzt die
bundesregierung auf einen dreiklang aus
diplomatie entwicklungs und
verteidigungspolitik die
entwicklungspolitik mit ihrem
langfristigen ansatz ihrer partner
orientierung und ihrer starken lokalen
verankerung ist ein kernstück dieser
strategie
gleichzeitig kann die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gerade durch
diese vernetzung schnell reagieren und
negative folgen von kriegen abfedern
nahrungsmittelknappheit und steigende
energiepreise dürfen unsere
partnerländer und das internationale
system nicht weiter destabilisieren und
dieser ansatz zahlt sich aus laut
berechnung der weltbank reduziert jeder
euro der in resilienz investiert wird
die kosten künftiger humanitärer krisen
um mindestens vier euro liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte die
gelegenheit hier nutzen danke zu sagen
danke für die unterstützung für die
entwicklungspolitik in den beratungen
zum haushalt 2022
13,35 milliarden euro für
entwicklungspolitik das ist das ergebnis
unserer gemeinsamen arbeit hier und
darauf werden wir weiter aufbauen
mussten durch den völkerrechtswidrigen
angriff russlands auf die ukraine sehen
wir alle die notwendigkeit von
entwicklungszusammenarbeit hier in
europa und ich bin der letzte woche in
die ukraine gereist um den
entwicklungspolitischen park vor ort zu
betonen und noch mal über unsere zivile
unterstützung zu sprechen mein
ministerium hat ende februar mit einem
sofortprogramm auf den russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine reagiert
und mit ihrer unterstützung hier liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen konnten wir
unser sofortprogramm verstetigen und so
werden wir auch in zukunft einen beitrag
leisten können das
entwicklungsministerium knüpft damit an
die seit 1993 bestehende zusammenarbeit
mit der ukraine an und sie baut auf der
partnerschaft mit
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
den kirchlichen zentralstellen
politischen stiftungen sowie mit
internationalen organisationen auf ein
kernstück ist die zusammenarbeit mit
ukrainischen kommunen sie funktioniert
und sie ist ein beleg dafür dass
entwicklungspolitik mittel und
langfristig wirkt denn die kommunen
setzen gerade jetzt maßgeblich das
entwicklungspolitische sofortprogramm
schnell und sehr wirksam und ich kann
ihnen versichern dass unsere
unterstützung vor ort wirklich dringend
benötigt wirklich war am freitag in
borodjanka das ist ganz in der nähe von
kiew dort ist ein
traurig ist ein furchtbares beispiel für
die zerstörung durch die russischen
soldaten und jetzt wenige woche nach dem
abzug der russischen truppen es nicht
nur die notversorgung wiederhergestellt
sondern beruht janka nimmt zusätzlich
noch binnenflüchtlinge auf und ich bin
wirklich beeindruckt von der kraft der
menschen dem leid etwas entgegenzusetzen
[Applaus]
sie hat
ja vielen dank frau ministerin dass sie
zwischen frage zu lassen und keine
selbstverständlichkeit in dem haus ich
will sie konkret fragen sie hatten es
gerade selber angesprochen es gibt eine
zusammenarbeit in dem fall hatten sie
die ukraine genannt seit 1993
was mich immer wieder bei der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit bei der
deutschen beschäftigt ist dass man viele
jahrzehnte mit staaten zusammenarbeitet
aber wir eigentlich den grundsatz hilfe
zur selbsthilfe verfolgen was glauben
sie wielange ist es eigentlich richtig
mit staaten zusammenzuarbeiten bevor man
eben an den punkt kommt dass man
dauerhaft staatliche aufgaben übernimmt
das kann ja nicht ziel deutscher
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sein was will
diese bundesregierung in zukunft in
diesem zusammenhang anders machen wollen
sie das mal zeitlich begrenzen es kann
nicht sein dass wir jahrzehnte
staatliche aufgaben übernehmen und dann
starten sie hatten gerade die ukraine
genannt wenn wir den korruptions index
anschauen immer noch bei ländern wie
angola und co angesiedelt sind vielen
dank
der vielen dank für die frage in der
zusammenarbeit mit der ukraine haben wir
es geschafft kommunale strukturen
aufzubauen wir haben es geschafft von
über 11.000 gemeinden jetzt zu rund 1700
gemeinden zu kommen die dann eben vom
staat auch zusätzliche aufgaben bekommen
haben und diese struktur zahlt sich
jetzt gerade auch in so einer
krisensituation sind das jetzt
funktionierende einheiten sind das
kommunale verwaltung die schnell
reagieren können und es zeigt dass
solche langfristigen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sehr
erfolgreich ist wir müssen jeweils
gucken was ist in den partnerländern
notwendig wie ist die situation vor ort
man kann nicht vorhersagen na klar in
fünf jahren würde es einen krieg geben
und deswegen machen wir jetzt wie es und
jenes das lässt sich nicht so einfach
planen und deswegen ist der unmittelbare
kontakt und dieses partnerschaftliche
auf augenhöhe und eben nicht sagen wir
wissen alles besser das ist die
grundlage unserer entwicklungspolitik
und das werden wir auch weiter
fortsetzen
wird vielleicht auch die gelegenheit
nochmal zu sagen dass wir eben seit
vielen jahren mit solchen gemeinden wie
borodjanka in der ukraine zusammen
arbeiten und ich war sehr froh dass ich
jetzt in kiel versichern konnte unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen dort dass wir
ein starker partner war bleiben werden
wir werden diese unterstützung weiter
ausbauen wir werden uns am wiederaufbau
einer freien und demokratischen ukraine
beteiligen und unser kanzler olaf scholz
hat hier ist ja heute hier in der
debatte noch einmal eindeutig gesagt wir
werden die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer so
lange unterstützen wie es nötig ist die
folgen des krieges sind darüber hinaus
aber eben auch weltweit zu spüren es
droht die schwerste hungersnot seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg die g7
entwicklungsministerin und minister
haben mitte mai deshalb gemeinsam mit
der weltbank das bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit gestartet das
bündnis dass ich vorangetrieben habe
wird bestehende strukturen zur
bekämpfung von hunger unter einem dach
zusammenfassen und kurz und
langfristiges engagement international
koordinieren unsere zusage von 430
millionen euro für ernährungssicherheit
war ein ganz wichtiges signal an unsere
partner und mein dank geht an sie dass
sie diese zusage noch während der
vorläufigen haushaltsführung möglich
gemacht haben
aber das habe ich schon mal gesagt der
russische angriffskrieg wird auch folgen
haben über die unmittelbaren folgen in
der ukraine in den entwicklungsländern
es zieht sich durch die heutige debatte
es erfordert eine neue
sicherheitspolitik mit einer gut
ausgerüsteten bundeswehr einer klugen
diplomatie sowie einer starken
entwicklungspolitik die im künftigen
krisen vorbeugen die schwerpunkte meiner
arbeit bleiben der kampf gegen hunger
und armut die justin sischen also der
fähre wandel hin zu einer klimaneutralen
welt der einsatz gegen cupid 19 und für
resilient ihre gesundheitssysteme und
eine feministische entwicklungspolitik
als zentraler beitrag für gerechtigkeit
und krisenprävention und
belege sind kollegen ich erinnere mich
noch gut an die erste lesung unter allen
demokratischen fraktionen waren wir uns
einig dass der zweite regierungsentwurf
für den bmz haushalt den globalen
herausforderungen nicht gerecht wird
jetzt stehen für dieses jahr 13 35
milliarden euro für die
entwicklungspolitik zur verfügung das
ist in etwa das niveau der ausgaben mit
denen das bmz das jahr 2021
abgeschlossen hat und diese
haushaltsansatz erlaubt es
entwicklungsländer bei der bewältigung
der coop 19 pandemie weiter zu
unterstützen und von den
koalitionsfraktionen wurden wichtige
umschichtungen vorgenommen etwa zur
stärkung einer feministischen
entwicklungspolitik und in der
bereinigungssitzung wurden noch
zusätzliche mittel bereit gestellt dass
es so gekommen ist das war keine
selbstverständlichkeit und ich danke
ihnen hier ausdrücklich für die
unterstützung
sei aber auch ganz deutlich
sorgen bereitet mir damit komme ich auch
zum ende der ausblick auf die kommenden
jahre 20 23 sind in der finanzplanung
bisher nur 10,7 milliarden euro
vorgesehen angesichts anhaltender
herausforderungen bietet dies bereits
jetzt die bestehenden realitäten nicht
mehr ob die folge des hoffentlich bald
beendeten russischen krieges werden uns
lange fordern in der ukraine in den
östlichen partnerländern und den vielen
entwicklungsländern afghanistan syrien
und der nahe osten der sahel und das
horn von afrika bleiben hotspots von
konflikten und hunger und die verstärkte
zusammenarbeit mit vielen ländern asiens
afrikas und lateinamerikas ist
erforderlich um den globalen
herausforderungen vor ort forderungen
vor allem dem klimawandel und dem
verlust an biologischer vielfalt
wirklich gemeinsam begegnen zu können
deutschland muss auch in zukunft einen
angemessenen beitrag zur agenda 2030
leisten können auch damit wir die
militärischen fähigkeiten die wir jetzt
schaffen möglichst nicht nutzen müssen
hier setzt sich auch weiterhin auf ihre
unterstützung für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und sage
nochmal ganz herzlichen dank
vielen dank frau ministerin
nächster redner ist der kollege dr
michael spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kolleginnen liebe zuschauer im
saal und bei youtube der etat des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung hat in
diesem jahr eine höhe von 13,35
milliarden euro dazu kommen noch mal
verpflichtungsermächtigung also fest
geplante ausgaben in den kommenden
haushaltsjahren von 10,7 milliarden euro
das ist schon eine ganz schön heftige
summe für projekte von denen eigentlich
keiner so genau weiß was mit dem geld
passiert wohin es fließt und was ist
tatsächlich nutzt genau über bedingten
ausgaben des auswärtigen amtes gibt es
beim bmz keine gesamtübersicht darüber
welche projekte wo in der welt mit dem
geld der deutschen steuerzahler
finanziert werden das ministerium
gelobte besserung und verspricht die
veröffentlichung eines transparents
portals im dritten quartal 2022 wir
warten gespannt darauf denn einen
überblick tut not bei allen maßnahmen
des bmz haben wir ebenso wie beim
auswärtigen amt zum grundlegende
evaluierungs probleme und die gibt es
längst nicht nur in der bilateralen
zusammenarbeit sondern auch in der
multilateralen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
der etat des bmz hat sich in den letzten
zehn jahren verdoppelt und im zuge
dessen floss auch immer mehr mittel an
multilaterale organisationen wie zum
beispiel die vereinten nationen wenn man
den vertretern der bundesregierung dann
zuhört wird man immer wieder dass es
sich dabei um zitat bewährte partner
handelt man überweist dann diese partner
zusammen mit anderen geberländern
milliardenbeiträge und mit der
überweisung fühlt man sich sofort total
gut klopft sich auf die schulter was man
denn so wieder tolles erreicht hat aber
was wurde eigentlich erreicht es gibt
bei den maßnahmen von multilateralen
organisationen oft keine zielgerichtete
steuerung und keine angemessene
erfolgskontrolle wenn das geld
überwiesen ist haben wir als geberland
erstmal keine handhabe mehr der
bundesrechnungshof ist nicht mehr
zuständig und abgesehen davon hat er
ohnehin schon zu wenig personal um die
hauseigenen projekte des bmz mal richtig
durch prüfen zu können
[Applaus]
wenn es um die mittelverwendung bei den
vereinten nationen geht dann gibt es
dort neben einer internen kontrolle als
unabhängige kontrollinstanz noch das
sogenannte board of the doors eine art
rechnungshof des un obwohl die prüfer
des boards ihren charakter als externe
kontrolle organisation gerne betonen
sind zweifel an der gründlichkeit herr
vorgenommenen prüfung schon rein aus
kapazitätsgründen nicht ganz von der
hand zu weisen und so verwundert es auch
nicht dass erst kürzlich ein
finanzskandal bei den vereinten nationen
nur aufgrund der veröffentlichung eines
whistleblowers ans licht kam der aus
indien stammende ehemalige un berater
lukas kapeller enthüllte auf seinem blog
dass beim büro für projekt dienste der
vereinten nationen genannt und
misswirtschaft betrug und korruption an
der tagesordnung waren dort hatte man
sich durch starke töne an
entwicklungshilfegeldern bereichert
außerdem sollten für 63 millionen dollar
bezahlbarer wohnraum für die ärmsten der
welt und investitionen in erneuerbare
energien getätigt werden doch nicht ein
einziges dieser projekte wurde bisher
verwirklicht nach der nato
generalsekretär zu besuch in washington
das wollten wir ihnen natürlich zeigen
und sind deswegen kurz aus dem bundestag
rausgegangen vor allem vor dem
hintergrund dass us-präsident beiden
jahr angekündigt hat fortschritt
fortschrittlichere raketensysteme an die
ukraine zu geben und bundeskanzler olaf
scholz heute morgen hier im bundestag
gesagt hat dass aus beständen der
bundeswehr möglichst bis ende juni
mehrfach raketenwerfer geliefert werden
sollen an die ukraine das geschehe in
enger abstimmung mit der usa die dann
auch die ausbildung der ukrainischen
soldaten an dem system übernehmen wir
sind zurück hier eben den beratungen zum
haushalt 2022 der letzte einzel plan für
heute zumindest am zweiten tag steht
jetzt auf der tagesordnung vor wenigen
minuten hat die dazugehörige
ministerinnen gesprochen es geht um den
einzelplan 23 für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung da gab es einen aufwuchs
bereinigtes 12 35 milliarden und die
ministerin svenja schulze wie gesagt
hatte vor wenigen minuten gesprochen wir
wollen ihnen das von vorne zeigen und
starten so in den einzelplan
kollege
nächste redner ist der kollege felix
paschek wanderschaft bündnis 90/grüne
ja endlich wird kolleginnen und kollegen
nach der rede freue ich mich über jeden
euro die der in multilaterale
organisation fließt und nicht in die
finanzierung solcher organisationen hier
aber jetzt zur sache
wir werden in dieser woche noch über ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr zur
steigerung unserer bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit
debattieren und beschließen und ich
werde wie viele von ihnen dafür stimmen
weil ich es richtig finde in der
aktuellen situation geopolitischer
herausforderungen die bundeswehr so
auszustatten dass die
verteidigungsfähigkeit da ist aber
glauben sie mit den hinweis gerade mit
blick auf das von der frau ministerin
geschilderte dass ich eine gewisse
schlagseite in den letzten wochen der
debatte unsere außenpolitischen
herausforderungen wahrgenommen habe
insbesondere aus ihren reihen die
einseitig das militärische betonten und
viel zu wenig über all die
diplomatischen die humanitären und die
präventiven mittel gesprochen haben und
ich halte das für notwendig
halte es für notwendig dass wir diese
schlagseite in den nächsten jahren
überwinden er lautete bitte ein zweiter
bemerkung dass mir die eine oder andere
debatte auch über die auswirkungen des
krieges in der ukraine auf die situation
hier in deutschland
merkwürdig vorkommen wenn ich mir
anschaue wie tiefgreifend die
auswirkungen der ukraine des
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine auf die region und auch
beispielsweise teile des afrikanischen
kontinents sind vorüber massive
hungersnöte sprechen wo wir über
gewaltausbrüche und drohende gewalt in
den nächsten jahren sprechen ich würde
mir wünschen wenn wir uns für die
nächsten jahre vornehmen würden ein teil
der selbstbezüglichkeit der deutschen
und europäischen debatte zu überwinden
und das globale stärker zu gewichten
auch in der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
herr kollege körper ich habe mir
ihre rede gerade sehr genau angeschaut
und angehört und ich finde sie müssen
sich schon entscheiden wollen sie jetzt
sagen dass die ampel haushälter
sozusagen willfährige erfüllungsgehilfen
des ministeriums sind oder wollen sie
was wir getan haben anerkennen was alles
von seite der koalition zwischen der
erste zwischen dem ersten
regierungsentwurf und jetzt unserer dem
zweiten regierungsentwurf und dieser
vorlage über die wir diese woche
abstimmen passiert ist ich würde aus
ihrer sicht da auch ein bisschen
kleinere brötchen backen denn ich kann
mich an eine bereinigungssitzung eltern
wo von ihrer seite überhaupt keine
erinnerung vorschläge mehr kamen wo wir
ausschließlich noch vorschläge anderer
oppositionsfraktionen und eben der
koalitionsfraktionen hatten wie genau
die richtigen schwerpunkte gesetzt haben
und da sie hier gerade so ein gemälde
von gerd müller gezeichnet haben sie
scheinen der großen abschieds schmerzen
zu empfinden will ich ihnen sagen was
das gute daran ist dass nicht mehr geld
müller sondern svenja schulze ministerin
dieses hauses ist dass eine neue
koalition neue schwerpunkte setzen wird
wir
wissen sie wie hoch der anteil der
programme 2009 10 war die sich explizit
beispielsweise mit der stärkung der
rechte von frauen und mädchen
auseinandergesetzt hat die sogenannte
gg2 kennung
2,38 prozent das ist 2,8 38 prozent des
gesamten centers sind dafür ausgegeben
worden insbesondere die akteurinnen zu
stärken die in krisen eine sehr große
bedeutung daran haben krisen zu
überwinden und deswegen haben wir uns in
der koalition darauf verständigt dem
ministerium den auftrag zu geben weil
wir eben selbstbewusste haushälterin und
haushälter sind jetzt bis zur sitzung im
herbst ein plan vorzubereiten wird
dieser anteil gesteigert werden kann und
dann wenn wir genau darüber diskutieren
was mit dem geld passieren soll damit
eben die richtigen schwerpunkte gesetzt
werden eine feministische
entwicklungszusammenarbeit eine
feministische geopolitik die wird
absolut notwendig seien und die großen
krisen unserer zeit zu bewältigen
deswegen streiken wir beispielsweise
auch die reproduktiven rechte gerade die
gehen in konfliktsituationen
besonders in gefahr und
und wir werden mehr geld über alle
einzelpläne hinweg für den
internationalen klima und
biodiversitätsschutz ausgeben zwar ihre
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die das
ziel ausgegeben hat bis ende dieser
legislaturperiode 6 milliarden euro für
globalen klima und biodiversitätsschutz
zu geben und ja da haben wir noch
einiges in der lücke zu füllen das haben
in anderen bereichen auch aber keine
koalition vor dieser ampel koalition hat
jemals ernsthaft den versuch unternommen
dieses ziel zu erreichen
wir stärken den klimaschutz wir stärken
die biodiversität explizit
beispielsweise programme die sich an die
energie indigenen bevölkerung in aller
welt richten die diese unterstützung
besonders brauchen das ist eine ampel
schwerpunkten sie sich nie zugetraut
haben und deswegen
sehe ich die großen herausforderungen
mit blick auf die finanzplanung ich sehe
die großen herausforderung mit blick auf
die herausforderung die einfach in der
welt da sind aber ich bin zuversichtlich
dass es uns als ampel gelingen wird
ihnen besser gerecht zu werden als die
vorgängerregierung vielen vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
als nächster hält das wort ich lese club
berlin fraktion will
herzlichen dank herr präsident meine
damen und herren die spaltung zwischen
arm und reich hat sich im letzten jahren
massiv verschärft hier im land aber auch
weltweit das ist kein naturereignis
sondern es folgen einer politik die zum
einen millionen menschen im stich lässt
und auf der anderen seite milliardäre
immer reicher macht und die linke sagt
ganz klar das darf so nicht weitergehen
es muss geändert werden
allein während der korona pandemie ist
das vermögen der milliardäre weltweit um
unfassbare 42 prozent auf 12,7 millionen
us dollar gestiegen auf der anderen
seite wird allein in diesem jahr mehr
als eine viertel milliarde menschen
zusätzlich verarmen schon jetzt gehen 88
111 millionen menschen jede nacht
hungrig zu bett darunter viele kinder
276 millionen sind 100 guter hungersnot
betroffenen das ist mehr als doppelt so
viel wie vor drei jahren
auch das zeigt explosion der
lebensmittelpreise muss sofort gestoppt
werden das ist menschenverachtend
die vereinten nationen zählen erstmals
mehr als 100 millionen menschen auf der
flucht es ist ein rekord ist niemals
hätte geben dürfen sagte un kommissar
filippo grandi recht hat er was macht
jetzt die bundesregierung in so einer
situation
müsste doch angst von unternehmen wie
noch nie um zur linderung der holt
beizutragen aber im märz zu beginn der
haushaltsberatungen gab es hier an den
wurf mit einer milliarden kürzungen
unfassbar dieses schlimme vorhaben
konnte durch viel öffentlichen protest
auch dank breit und engagement aus dem
parlament verhindert werden das ist
gesagt worden dennoch die bittere
wahrheit ist dass die ampel koalition in
diesem jahr trotz krieg in der ukraine
trotz steigender armut trotz hungersnot
weniger findet muss politik ausgibt als
die große koalition im letzten jahr es
sind es 290 millionen euro weniger das
an den kürzungen ist völlig falsch und
komplett aus der zeit gefallen meine
damen und herren
ein beispiel das entwicklungsprogramm
der vereinten nationen kann im letzten
jahren von der großen position um 620
millionen euro die ampel landet für
dieses jahr trotz zwei ergänzungen nur
bei 92 millionen euro und das ist ein
programm das ist im zweifel noch vor ort
in einem land wo alle anderen
organisationen schon raus sind für die
linke ist klar dieses programm darf auf
gar keinen fall gekürzt werden erst
[Applaus]
dann wissen sie auch nicht besonders
entsetzt als ihr ministerium über den
entwurf gesprochen haben habe ich
gefragt warum wollen sie ausgerechnet
beim welternährungsprogramm
56 prozent der deutschen mittel kürzen
also mehr als die hälfte die antwort des
regierungsvertreters spd war wir müssen
kürzen und da ist es technisch einfach
möglich ich bitte sie man kurz doch
nicht bei den ärmsten weil es technisch
möglich ist das kein technischer falls
eine politische entscheidung
da wo die not besonders groß ist da
kürzt man nicht
und dieses klosters umso empörender bei
zugleich für atombombe für kampfdrohnen
und so weiter auf einmal 100 milliarden
euro extra gas sind es ist immer eine
gute frage wofür das geld da ist und
wofür nicht machen sie den menschen
nichts vor
dem spiel war wird sich zu entnehmen
dass spd fraktionschef rolf mützenich
mit kanzler scholz als gegenleistung für
die aufrüstung milliarden ausgehandelt
hat das ist ein aufwuchs bei den mitteln
gibt für die entwicklungszusammenarbeit
wir sehen jetzt dass dieses plus nicht
einmal ausreicht um das minus für euch
zur großen positionen auszugleichen und
wissen sie dass spd-fraktionschef beim
kanzler darum betteln muss ein paar
millionen mehr entwicklung auszugeben
während zugleich für die
rüstungskonzerne milliarden
ausgeschüttet werden ist eine wirklich
unfassbar erscheint es sagt viel über
diese regierung aus meine damen und
herren
eine große sorge von uns von den
hilfsorganisationen ist dass die mittel
den nächsten jahren wieder gekürzt
werden weil sie zum beispiel im
ergänzungs haus hat nur einmalig
eingestellt worden sind unsere welt muss
aber friedlicher und gerechter werden
dazu muss deutsch in einem verlässlichen
beitrag leisten dafür setzen die linke
und zweiter 1
anstatt alle menschen im stich zu lassen
hier zu lande und in der welt muss
politik ungerechtigkeit beenden und sich
mit den reichsten anlegen und ganz punkt
trägt es ist wirklich beschämend dass
bei einer hungerkrise in der welt sich
konzern und spekulanten auch daran
bereichern spekulation mit
nahrungsmitteln muss verboten werden
sich das gelitten
bis 30 vielen dank berlin nächste
rednern ist die kollegin claudia
grafischen fdp fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe frau ministerin schulze liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine ersten
haushaltsberatungen als neue haupt
berichterstatterin im einzelplan 23
gehen nun auf die zielgerade
gerade daher auch an dieser stelle
nochmals vielen dank an alle für diesen
angenehmen svenja schulze die
entwicklungsministerin hier zu ihrem
einzelplan das haben wir ihnen gleich
zeitversetzt gezeigt
ja sie war als zweites mitglied der
bundesregierung in kiew und hatte kam
nicht mit leeren händen
sozusagen die ukraine hat zivile hilfe
zugesagt bekommen 185 millionen euro
soforthilfe maßnahmen beispielsweise um
wohnungen wieder aufzubauen oder auch
stromleitungen insgesamt svenja schulze
zumindest mit dem nachschlag den der
haushaltsausschuss er nochmal bewilligt
hat ihrem ressort durchaus zufrieden die
rechnung da 12,35 milliarden stehen im
einzelplan und eine milliarde noch etwas
versteckt im einzelplan 60 für die
allgemeine finanzverwaltung
aber für die nächsten jahre sagt sie
müssen hier aus hält er muss das
parlament vielleicht noch mal drauf
schauen so wir sind mitten in der
aussprache zum einzelplan es spricht für
die fdp claudia raffelhüschen
investition mit sicherheit eine für
beide seiten sehr zufriedenstellende
rendite erwarten können wenn
man in die zusammenhang von rente
sprechen darf es ist gut dass wir auch
in der bereinigung diese linie
fortgesetzt haben und beispielsweise
nochmals fünf millionen in den gp ii
fand der vereinten nationen stecken mit
dieser global partnership for education
unterstützen wir nämlich die
verletzlichsten kinder in den ärmsten
ländern zu den mädchen leider fast
automatisch gehören der zugang zu guter
bildung ist für diese mädchen essentiell
um sich ein in jeder hinsicht
selbstbestimmtes leben aufzubauen
ökonomisch physisch und auch mental in
dieselbe richtung zielen die
zusätzlichen 20 millionen euro für den
child care center auch hier verfolgen
wir den nahe liegenden weg auf qualität
und bewährte multilaterale akteure zu
setzen ein ganz wichtiger punkt wenn wir
sicherstellen wollen dass unsere gelder
nicht unter dem motto gut gemeint aber
nicht gut gemacht versichert ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass nur eine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sinn und
zukunft hat die genau daran setzt bei
bildung und qualitativ hochwertige
betreuung und gesundheitsversorgung für
kinder
und natürlich bank im parlament von
mädchen es war nicht sonderlich
schwer vorauszusehen was die lage aber
umso bitterer der ukraine krieg und die
sanktionen gegen russland bedeuten für
viele länder vor allem in afrika das
hungersnöte schon jetzt kaum noch
abzuwenden sind oder das bereits
vorhandene nochmals verschärft wurden es
ist daher gut dass deutschland mit dem
geplanten bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit aktiv voran geht
und dabei sicherlich auch auf die
unterstützung des parlaments offen und
banker wichtig
wichtig ist aber auch dass wir diese
schreckliche situation nutzen um
bisherige schwachstellen und
versäumnisse entwicklungszusammenarbeit
kritisch zu beleuchten
sprich es ist auf dauer nicht zu führen
es ist auf dauer nicht zielführend auf
akute hungersnöte mit den immer gleichen
importen der immer gleichen produkte aus
ganz wenigen ländern zu reagieren wie
anfällig das system weizen aus russland
und der ukraine ist wird uns gerade
brutal vor augen geführt stattdessen
müssen wir sehr viel stärker an der
residenz der betroffenen staaten
arbeiten ökonomisch politisch und vor
allem in sachen ernährungssicherheit und
noch etwas
noch etwas ist uns wichtig dass wir
neben dem blick auf die akuten krisen
pandemie folgen hier ukraine krieg dort
nicht die vielen anderen globalen
herausforderungen aus dem blick
verlieren das wäre besonders bitter weil
wir hier ja durchaus schon einiges
erreicht haben jetzt das eine zu tun und
dafür das andere zu lassen das wäre
wirklich vertan daher war es auch ein so
wichtiges signal dass deutschland
zusätzlich 165 millionen euro in den
globalen fonds zur bekämpfung von aids
tuberkulose und malaria steckt denn
gerade in afrika
denn gerade afrika ist für 100
tatsächlich ein wesentlich geringeres
gesundheitsproblem als befürchtet
dagegen sind aids tuberkulose malaria
weiterhin massive bedrohungen die durch
die über große aufmerksamkeit auf
bewohner fast vergessen worden was sie
de facto noch gefährlicher machen zum
schluss möchte ich noch einmal auf das
zurückkommen was ich schon in der ersten
lesung gesagt habe und in meinen
reden immer wieder holen die
schuldenbremse ist keine unzumutbarkeit
sie ist zumindest in krisenzeiten auch
kein selbstzweck sie ist aber ganz
einfach das beste instrument für
haushalterische nachhaltigkeit dass wir
haben probleme und nur die
schuldenbremse schnell wieder einhalten
kann deutschland sich langfristig
leisten in absoluten zahlen der
zweitgrößte und relativ zur bevölkerung
in vielen bereichen sogar der größte
geber in der internationalen
zusammenarbeit der entwicklung zu
bleiben das ist unser ziel kindern
dann sagen wir claudia raffelhüschen
gefühl die fdp-fraktion sie ist eine der
berichterstatterin für diesen einzelplan
jetzt können wir den sprecher für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung der union volkmar klein
was sie nennt meine
damen und herren
die beiträge
haben schon so ein bisschen deutlich
gemacht dass in diesem jahr der
einzelplan 23 oder ich will mal besser
sagen die finanzierung der arbeit des
ministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung so
unübersichtlich sind wie in der
vergangenheit noch nie
anfangs
vorübergehend 600 millionen euro im
zweiten regierungsentwurf im einzelplan
60 schon arg geparkt um
überplanmäßige ausgaben zu finanzieren
784 millionen euro für lte also die
internationale impfkampagne aber neben
dem einzelplan 23 und eine milliarde
aus dem ergänzungs haushalt für
kriegsfolgen bewältigung weiterhin im
einzelplan 60 und nicht im einzelplan 23
globale mehrausgaben
nicht
klar ist wer und wie entscheidet wo die
am ende ausgegeben werden das ist schon
ein stück problem für die transparenz
der finanzierung unserer
entwicklungsarbeit gründe man ja sagen
ja das ist ja nicht so schlimm könnte ja
sogar
besonders kreativ und deswegen gut sein
mag sein aber es wird natürlich
erhebliche gefahren weil der plattform
des einzelplan 23 ist eben nicht
entsprechend aufgewachsen nicht die
mittelfristige finanzplanung ist problem
für die zukunft aber immer als benchmark
die bisherigen ausgaben und die sind
eben sehr viel niedriger als die
gesamtsumme über die jetzt mehrfach
geredet worden ist
vielleicht hat sich die ministerin ein
bisschen über und 16 lassen vom
finanzminister weil wenn ich dann sehe
wenn ich dann sehe
dass die vsg die
verpflichtungsermächtigung im einzelplan
23 deutlich zurückgefahren worden sind
hinter das niveau von 2021 dann liebe
frau kollegin hagedorn ist das für mich
ein sicheres indiz dafür dass meine
befürchtung sehr wohl substantiiert es
aber fangen wir mal vorne an positiv
ich möchte mich ganz ganz herzlich
bedanken
bei den ampel
koalitionsfraktionen dafür dass sie sich
unserer kritik am ursprünglichen entwurf
der bundesregierung angeschlossen haben
dass sie sehr massiv dass sie sehr
massiv auch eingefallen sind in die
kritik der opposition an das was die
regierung vorgelegt hat
opposition wird das kann man so ein
bisschen feststellen das betrifft die
gesamtsumme
weil sie haben ja gerade nochmal so die
kurve gekriegt
das betrifft aber auch einzelpunkte
einige wurden ja eben schon genannt also
zu kürzen die sonder initiative eine
welt ohne hunger angesichts der jetzigen
situation das war doch absurd den krisen
titel wollte die regierung von 936
millionen auf 550 millionen kürzen wäre
doch ein unding gewesen es ist gut dass
das alles
korrigiert worden ist dass die kürzung
des kirchen titels
zurückgenommen worden sind deswegen ich
kann nur sagen es
ist sehr gut dass sie in letzter minute
sich unserer kritik angeschlossen haben
und notwendige kurskorrekturen
vorgenommen haben das loben wir
auf der anderen seite gibt es schon an
vielen stellen einen erheblichen dissens
zwischen reden und handeln
jetzt ist eben noch mal gesagt worden
wie wichtig doch die förderung von
frauen ist hat das bmz auch eben in
einer pressemitteilung noch mal raus
gegeben und wenn ich dann aber sehe das
genau da wo hauptsächlich frauen
gefördert werden weiterhin eine massive
kürzung da ist dann passt doch reden und
handeln nicht zusammen vielleicht weiß
die ministerin nicht vielleicht weiß die
ministerin nicht dass mikrokredite vor
allen dingen frauen zugute kommen herr
kollege seine zwischenfrage aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die ja gerne
vielen dank herr kollege klein nachdem
sie jetzt zwei minuten finde sehr
spannende ausführungen über
einzelplan systematiken genutzt haben
haben sie jetzt den weg zum inhalt
gefunden meine frage wäre an welchen
stellen sie also nochmal darstellen
können an welchen stellen jetzt ihrer
auffassung nach weniger für frauen
bezogene programm ausgehen wird
beispielsweise auch als in ihrem ersten
regierungsentwurf der schwarz-roten
vorgängerregierung wir haben ja nämlich
nicht nur einen zentralen auf wachs von
dem zweiten regierungsentwurf zu dem was
wir uns diese woche debattieren sondern
hier einen genauso großen auf wachs
gegenüber dem von ihrer regierung
vorgelegten vorgängerin vorgänger
entwurf wir haben beispielsweise
deswegen gemeinsam mit der regierung in
einem guten miteinander programme
beispielsweise für die finanzierung von
frauen also das bff dass sie vielleicht
gerade im bereich mikrokredite
ansprechen wollten wieder auf das niveau
gebracht wo es war wir haben die un
women gestärkt übrigens mehr als jemals
in einer vorgängerregierung dafür
ausgegeben wurde und wir haben auch
beispielsweise programme konnte frau
dazwischen das gerade ausgeführt in
richtung reproduktive rechte
familienplanung und so weiter erhöht
gegenüber dem was ihre vorgänger
regierung zustande gebracht hat
vielleicht kann es einfach noch mal
zahlen darstellen wo ich mich getäuscht
haben könnte
das ist schön dass sie die frau kollegin
raffelhüschen gerade nochmal erwähnt
haben die zurecht darauf hingewiesen hat
dass an vielen stellen frauen
die besseren unternehmerinnen sind und
dass es deswegen sehr sinnvoll ist genau
dort wirtschaftlich anzusetzen und
möglicherweise wissen sie nicht dass das
besonders wirksam über mikrokredite
möglich ist und möglicherweise wissen
sie auch nicht und möglicherweise weiß
dass auch die ministerin nicht dass der
titel im haushalt zusammenarbeit mit der
wirtschaft das ist der titel aus dem der
wesentliche für die wesentliche
finanzierung für die sparkassen stiftung
fließt und die finanzieren vor allen
dingen mikrokredite und wenn ich jetzt
sehe dass dieser titel von
267 millionen euro auf 194 millionen
gekürzt worden ist dann ist das für mich
das gegenteil von förderung von frauen
und ich will noch eine weitere zahl
hinzusetzen
ich hatte nämlich gestern gelegenheit
mit dem präsidenten der
sparkassenstiftung darüber zu reden weil
ich habe gesagt das sind 90 prozent die
frauen zugute kommen und heinrich haasis
hat mich korrigiert und hat gesagt in
vielen programmen der sparkassenstiftung
sind es 100 prozent das heißt sie kürzen
den titel der 100 prozent frauen zugute
kommt und das ist für mich das gegenteil
von der frage förderung von frauen und
insofern ja
das ist schon ein skandal sowie kollegen
am 100 prozent gerecht deswegen ist das
etwas was sie sich sehr zu herzen nehmen
müssten und ganz generell bin ich
einfach sagen das ist auch ein
erfolgreiches motto aus nordrhein
westfalen reden reicht mich es geht
darum machen woran wohlauf ist genau wie
das ensi abschluss bringen was wir eben
auch von der ampelkoalition erwarten und
wenn sie das machen dann haben wir
unsere unterstützung dabei vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste gegnerin ist die kollegin
bettina hagedorn spd fraktion
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
lieber volkmar klein
ihr habt hier als union am 23 märz in
unserer ersten lesung massiv in der tat
kritisiert wie niedrig mit 10,9
milliarden euro der etat war
und das übrigens haben wir auch getan
und das hat auch die ministerin gemacht
und wir haben jetzt 2,4 milliarden euro
mehr zur verfügung für das raus ich
werde gleich noch näher darauf eingehen
und das ist ein großer erfolg und das
könnte zwar versuchen klein zu halten
aber es werde nicht schaffen
und nun ist es so dass wir uns
vorgenommen hatten gemeinsam auch die
ministerin dass wir natürlich auch
eigene schwerpunkte setzen wollen das
heißt ja nicht dass wir mit der politik
des vorgängers gerd müller aufräumen
aber klar ist auch dass wenn man neue
schwerpunkte setzen will und das soll
nicht alles nur und topcom was ja die
union massiv kritisieren würde wenn wir
es getan hätten dann muss man eben auch
umschichten und da muss an projekte auch
evaluieren und eins ist natürlich ganz
klar da es eine verminte minister
entwicklungspolitik die unter heidemarie
heidemarie wieczorek zeul bis 2009
praktiziert und erfunden worden ist und
jetzt endlich in der gestalt von svenja
schulze wieder einen deutlichen
schwerpunkt erfährt in den zehn jahren
dazwischen
naja ein bisschen vor sich hin gedümpelt
hat und natürlich
hat es auch im haushalt von gerd müller
zum beispiel projekte zur mikro zins
finanzierung gegeben die finde ich super
die finden wir glaube ich alle super die
sind allseits anerkannt aber trotzdem
ist es so dass der eigene zusätzliche
schwerpunkte setzen und claudia düffel
ist ausführlich darauf eingegangen und
immer wenn man frauen stärkt wenn man
ihre rechtsposition stärkt wenn man sie
wirtschaftlich gestärkt dann steht man
auch die kinder dann stark man auch die
gesundheit der kinder dann investiert
man auch daran dass die frauen sich
darum kümmern dass es eine auskömmliche
zukunft für ihre kinder gibt und dann
wird man gleichzeitig fluchtursachen
entgegen dann befriedet man gleichzeitig
region und darum es eine solche
entwicklungs politik für und mit frauen
in erster linie auch eine politik die
den frieden stabilisierte privat
präventiv wirkt und dass es unser
hauptziel gemeinsam
und dazu gehört auch ein zweiter
schwerpunkt der auch in dieser ampel
koalition natürlich viel stärker betont
als er bisher betont worden ist und
darauf sind wir gemeinsam stolz und das
ist der einsatz für klimaschutz und für
biodiversität besteht auch so in unserem
koalitionsvertrag und auch da haben wir
eine priorität gesetzt und auch das ist
natürlich ein punkt der klimawandel der
trifft die ärmsten immer im herbst das
ist auch in unserem eigenen land so aber
das ist auch weltweit und es ist
natürlich so dass die folgen des
klimawandels
vorrangig auch länder die sowieso schon
von dürren von starkregenereignissen von
sturm von überschwemmungen also von all
den dingen gekennzeichnet sind die
wirklich die lebensgrundlage der
menschen wenden nehmen die die menschen
zur flucht zwingen
die armut und die natürlich auch im
kampf um land und rohstoffe den krieg
befeuern unter nationen gerade im
südlichen teil der halbkugel und weil
das so ist ist es gut und es ist richtig
dass wir einen deutlichen schwerpunkt
setzen und ich glaube es ist eine gute
fügung dass unsere ministerin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung im nicht nur den
feministischen schwerpunkt setzten sich
im märz angekündigt hat sondern dass sie
in ihrer vorherigen verwendung auch
umweltministerin in dieser regierung war
und dass vor diesem hintergrund ein
völlig anderes verständnis für den kampf
für den klimaschutz mitbringt als es
andere vorgänge erfolg hatten und vor
diesem hintergrund glaube ich haben wir
gemeinsam einen guten wurf hingekriegt
eines möchte ich noch betonen welche
missverständnisse zu sein scheint ich
bedanke mich bei den für die guten
beratung nicht nur unsere haupt
berichterstatterin claudia finnischen
und felix walleczek und unseren
gemeinsamen teams sondern auch der
ministerin denn einstimmig lieber
carsten körper das ist hier nicht alles
von den ampelkoalition von den
haushältern also ich nehme mir gerne
entgegen aber nur für etwas was wir
gemacht haben wir haben aus einem
ergänzungs haushalt und aus einem
kernhaushalt die haben wir zusammen
gefügt aber für den ergänzungs haushalt
hat die regierung gesagt und er hat es
werden ja schulze mit viel erfolg bei
christian lindner für eine milliarde
euro on top geworben und die bekommen
und es ist richtig und darum haben wir
jetzt eben noch die eine milliarde im
einzelplan 60 und das ist hervorragend
und wir haben eben auch über elf
überplanmäßige ausgaben mit eingefügte
in den haushalt die letzten endes auch
schon funken seinen kanzler in unserer
verantwortung weltweit zu gesagt und
versprochen worden sind und die sind
hier auch mit eingeflossen das heißt das
geld das haben nicht alles wir besorgt
aber wir haben die schwerpunkte gesetzt
gemeinsam in enger absprache auch mit
unserem haus und ich glaube das eg das
kann sich sehen lassen und vor dem
hintergrund will ich nur noch einmal
sagen 2,4 milliarden euro mehr das ist
schon ein richtig guter schwerpunkt aber
weil auch darauf schon bezug genommen
worden ist in dieser debatte ja wir
haben in dieser woche schon sehr viel
über das militär und über das
militärische besprochen und das ist auch
richtig so und ich werde auch ein
freitag aus voller überzeugung dem 100
milliarden euro vermögen zu stimmen und
wir haben ja gleich noch einer
haushaltsausschuss sitzung wo wir uns
damit noch intensiv beschäftigen werden
aber eins ist aufwarten militärisches
ist immer das letzte mittel und jeder
cent jeder euro den wir in die
prävention stecken und den werden die
langfristige stabilisierung von region
und die menschen die dort leben stecken
ist ein viel kommt als ein vielfaches
zurück und ist immer immer die bessere
lösung als das militärische das ist der
eine punkt den ich sagen möchte und der
andere punkt ist der dass wir mit diesem
etat die ministerin hat ihre sorgen mit
blick auf den einzelplan 23 als auf das
jahr 20 23 angesprochen diese sorge
teilen wir fakt ist liebe claudia wir
haben einen koalitionsvertrag der steht
die schuldenbremse drin ja und das werde
ich auch nicht infrage stellen ich habe
sie selbst mit eingeführt wir sind
koalitionstreu
aber trotzdem hoffe ich auch auf die
unterstützung und das verständnis
unseres finanzministers dass in diesem
weltweiten krisen die wir haben auch ein
finanzministerium natürlich mithilft und
hoffentlich mithelfen wird um die
balance zwischen ausgaben im
militärischen bereich und in dem bereich
die präventiv werken weltweit gerade in
diesem ressort aber auch im auswärtigen
amt herzustellen und das ist unsere
gemeinsame aufgabe ich bin ziemlich
sicher uns wirklich langweilig wir
hatten in den kommenden wochen monaten
aber wir haben uns in den ersten
haushaltsberatungen absolut wert der
sind ein system der den freundlich
miteinander um und für diese arbeit die
mir sehr viel freude gemacht habe möchte
ich mich ganz herzlich bei meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen bedanken vielen
dank sagt bettina hagedorn die
stellvertretende vorsitzende des
haushaltsausschusses
und jetzt folgt ihr thema friedhof von
der afg
[Applaus]
herr präsident werte kolleginnen
kollegen lieber bürgerinnen und bürger
frau ministerin es geht um
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung vielleicht besser bekannt
als gut finanzierte
entwicklungshilfe industrie um mir eins
klarzustellen die afg sieht die
kürzungen vor weil die art und weise wie
ihr geld verpufft weder ziel noch
erfolgsorientiert ist es ist seit 65
jahren falsch und der helfen neue
überschriften eben nicht denn wenn es ja
richtig und gut wäre müssten wir doch
eigentlich positive veränderungen sehen
und wahrnehmen aber wir tun es doch ich
werde das jetzt hier aufzeigen und als
erstes kommen wir zu dem
selbstverständnis der regierenden dr
hoffmann der fdp sagte in einer seiner
letzten reden
entwicklungsgelder zu kürzen wäre so als
ob man einem bettler in der
fußgängerzone den hut weg liegt und das
geld herausholen und genau dieses bild
was sie zeichnen wollen ist nicht das
bild was ich in afrika wahrnehmen und in
south africa überhaupt nicht gerecht
wird der arme der battle aber es zeigt
bewusst das dilemma zu entwickeln länder
auf gewollte abhängigkeiten von den
spenden deswegen fordern wir seit fünf
jahren eine ehrliche selbst
entwicklungspolitik die der menschen
mental kulturell und sozial gerecht wird
missstände klar aufzeigt und systemisch
denkt und handelt oder das
selbstverständnis der ministerin die bio
diverse klimagerechte feministische
entwicklungspolitik in die mitte des
ausblicks stellt das ist westlicher
ideologie export aber keine selbst
entwicklungsbank und übrigens die grünen
die ja so ihre probleme mit deutschland
haben wollen indigene völker in
lateinamerika schützen ich hoffe mit
ihrer sprache mit ihrer kultur mit ihren
werten und wenn das so ist dann bitte
liebe grüne beachten wir deutsche sind
auch indigene bevölkerung da ihnen
dieses selbstverständnis fehlt ist ihre
sicht eine falsche und damit auch ihr
lösungsansatz doch die schon richtig so
wie unsere ministerin zu karl may der in
seinem leben heime in amerika war jedoch
nie ein indianer gesehen hat aber das
bild der europäer über die indianer
prägt
die amerikaner haben die indianer zwangs
kultiviert man nahm ihn die
lebensgrundlagen steckte sie in
westliche kleidung und gab ihnen
westliche nahmen die geschichte ist uns
bekannt die indigene bevölkerung
amerikas wurde zum verlierer sozial
kulturell finanziell das indigene
verschwand und manche machten sie sogar
sozialer abhängig man hat ja
selbstverständlich gut gemeint und auch
jetzt meint man es sehr wieder gut aber
gut meinen heißt noch lange nicht gut
machen die zu entwicklern länder sind
arm wie nie hunger sind der umgang wie
nähe und sind vergehen wie niger mali
burkina faso südsudan zu dann und viele
andere länder sprechen bände allein in
äthiopien der einstigen entwicklungs
hoffnung am horn von afrika sind in den
letzten monaten tiger konflikt 509
500.000 menschen getötet worden aus
afghanistan werden nach wie vor tausende
von ortskräfte nach deutschland
ausgeflogen alles an
entwicklungsleistungen gegen den jahren
erbracht worden sind mit einem mal
erloschen ihre leuchttürme leuchtenden
das liegt eben auch daran dass diese
länder nicht selbst verantwortlich und
nicht reserviert entwickelt worden sind
weil ihre entwicklungsschwerpunkte
nichts aber auch überhaupt nichts mit
den lebensrealitäten der menschen vor
ort zu tun haben denn das macht eben
nicht sagt der chat hat 70 prozent der
tschad hat 70 nach ernteverluste und
hungert warum war ihre
entwicklungspolitik frau ministerin
hettich zielführend in mosambik wird
mais angebaut und günstig exportiert
damit muss ein big mail maismehl teuer
geld importiert und warum war es in
mosambik keine mühe gibt warum ist das
so 80 prozent der baumwolle aus berlin
verlässt berlin ohne weitere
wertschöpfung in benin warum ist das so
frau ministerin der afrikanische
kontinent wird mit billigen eu 17
subventionierte lebensmittel
zugeschüttet so dass sich der anbau in
den eigenen ländern gar nicht lohnt
warum ist das so frau minister
afrika liefert uns günstige kaffeebohnen
damit man bei uns dann foren
filterkaffee kauft warum ist das so nach
20 jahren verlorenen jahr in afghanistan
und den katastrophalen abzug der
westlichen truppen bricht über nacht
eine hungerkatastrophe in afghanistan
aus warum ist das so weil ihre ansätze
und ihre ideologien falschen
20 jahre nach ihrer politik in
afghanistan führten dazu dass es mehr
kokain felder als je zuvor in diesem
land gibt und
afghanistan wird marktführer im
drogenmarkt wurde auch hier kann ich
sagen kokain kann man leider nicht essen
aber der bilder grüne
landwirtschaftsminister daher ist mir
wohl einen trend folgen wenn er fordert
weniger lebensmittel in deutschland
anzubauen und stattdessen hand anzubauen
nun die politik der neuen regierung kann
man vermutlich auch momentan vertragen
fatale hier
dass die regierungsparteien einen antrag
abgelehnt haben sie haben letzte woche
ein antrag der cdu oder von zwei wochen
abgelehnt die nehme ich wollte dass wir
mehr weizen in zeitpunkt keine krise
hier in deutschen landen bauen und damit
afrika unterstützen sie haben es
abgelehnt weil man ja das deutsche
klimaziel nicht gefährdet und auch hier
ist ihre sicht liebe grüne eine falsche
ja wir erleben ein klimawandel es gibt
einen klimawandel einen natürlichen und
dieser stößt nun auf eine
umweltkatastrophe die mensch gemacht ist
und zwar das zerstören der weltweiten
wald ressourcen und der ungebremste
bevölkerungswachstums runter ungebremste
ressourcen werden aber das wollen sie
alles nicht wahr haben da steckt man
sich lieber seine es die c-17 bronze
herum und wird zum herr der ringe
beziehungsweise zu stein der weisen was
es braucht gerade für afrika mehr
wertschöpfung einen afrikanischen markt
um mehr industrie und in grundlastfähige
industrie ich komme gleich zum ende ja
das finde ich jetzt aus ist gut wissen
sie was da setzt die agenda 62 63 der
afrikanischen union sind für schlau und
unterstützen wir den zwölf bestimmten
weg selbstbestimmter völker sams
verantwortung dankeschön
vielen dank
nicht zu reden ist die kollegin
thüringen bündnis 90 die grünen
sprecherin für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung der
grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte ministerin schulze liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich
morgens die zeitung aufschlage dann
befällt mich jeden tag aufs neue ein
gefühl von traurigkeit von angst von
traurigkeit wenn ich lese die am
wochenende in der nigerianischen stadt
port hat bei einer massenpanik
31 menschen ums leben kommen weil sie
angst haben dass sie keine der
lebensmittelspenden mehr bekommen angst
wenn ich jeden tag lesen wie die
klimakrise dazu führt dass immer mehr
menschen ihr zuhause verlieren
gut wenn ich weiß dass wir als gesamte
staatengemeinschaft dafür verantwortlich
sind diese krisen zu verhindern und
tagtäglich damit zu scheitern drohen wir
wissen dass nicht nur die klimakrise
oder die nahrungsmittelkrise sondern
auch alle anderen krisen zu mehr
vertreibungen gewalt hunger und armut
führen werden und wir wissen dass die
aktuellen krisen immer mehr werden mit
diesem wissen stehe ich ehrlich gesagt
gespalten vor diesem haushalt denn
innerhalb dessen das wurde heute schon
viel gesagt haben wir alles rausgeholt
was möglich war wir konnten die
kürzungen von über 1,7 milliarden euro
zurücknehmen und wir werden im jahr 20
22 13 3 milliarden euro in globale
gerechtigkeit investieren das ist
dringend notwendig und genau der
richtige schritt
[Applaus]
und wir konnten auch grüne schwerpunkte
setzen das ist zum einen wie mein
kollege felix bahn hat ja gerade schon
erwähnte die internationale kino
biodiversitätspolitik und die
feministische entwicklungszusammenarbeit
es ist aber auch die unterstützung der
zivilgesellschaft
denn gerade in schwierigen politischen
kontexten sind es zivilgesellschaftliche
organisationen die besonders wichtige
entwicklungspolitische arbeit machen wir
haben 15 millionen euro mehr für private
träger rausgeholt und 7 millionen bei
der stärkung von internationalen medien
denn freie und kritische medien sind
einem elementare grundlage für die
demokratie
und und das erfreut mich ehrlich gesagt
besonders wir haben klargemacht
steuergelder bekommen nur politische
stiftungen die mit ihrer arbeit die
demokratie stärken und sie nicht zu
ersetzen und das ist ein riesenerfolg
wir haben in diesem haushalt viel
rausgeholt und ich freue mich wirklich
darüber und ich danke den haushälterin
und der ministerin und uns allen als
ampel fraktion für diese wunderbare
arbeit aber langfristig wird es nicht
reichen nur kürzungen einfach zu
vermeiden wir brauchen einen echten
aufwuchs dauerhaft mehr geld für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist ehrlich
gesagt kein nice to have es ist ein must
have
wenn wir
wenn wir es ernst meinen mit der
globalen gerechtigkeit müssten die
mittel für entwicklungszusammenarbeit
und humanitäre hilfe im haushalt in den
kommenden jahren wie die
verteidigungsausgaben gleich ansteigen
und das ist nicht verhandelbar dass es
notwendig und wir reden hier in der
haushaltsdebatte über abstrakte zahlen
aber diese zahlen können über leben und
tod entscheiden sie entscheiden darüber
ob die krisen und pandemien noch zu mehr
ungerechtigkeiten und konflikten führen
zeitenwende bedeutet nicht nur mehr
militärische sicherheit zeitenwende
bedeutet gerechtigkeit nach vorne zu
stellen weil es eben auch in unserem
interesse ist dass alle menschen auf
diesem planeten in sicherheit leben
nicht nur in sicherheit vor krieg auch
in sicherheit vor hunger vor allem vor
krankheit und chancenlosigkeit lassen
sie uns gemeinsam für diese sicherheit
global sorgen
thüringen war das für die grünen ja der
einzelplan 23 ist wie viele einzelpläne
dieses bundeshaushaltes geprägt zum
einen von der bekämpfung der coop 19
pandemie hier im einzelplan
beispielsweise in entwicklungsländern
aber auch was die krisenbewältigung die
ernährungssicherheit im zusammenhang mit
dem krieg gegen die ukraine anbelangt
viel arbeit gemacht an dieser stelle
davon durchaus darauf hinweisen dass wir
erst einmal noch den haushaltsentwurf
der alten regierung zur vorlage hatten
aber mit diesem haushalt zeigen wir
jetzt dass die bundesregierung schnell
und entschieden auch die mehrbedarfe und
weltweiten krisen reagiert und ich
möchte mich da erst mal insbesondere bei
meiner kollegin claudia raffelhüschen
aber auch bei den anderen kollegen aus
dem haushaltsausschuss kollegin hagedorn
kundige balzac und den kollegen aus dem
aus dem abz ganz herzlich für die gute
zusammenarbeit weil dieser arbeit
bedanken
wir haben auch gerade zuletzt noch
einiges erreicht so haben wir die
selbstbestimmung und menschenrechte von
frauen und mädchen durch erhöhte
beiträge an internationalen
organisationen wie dem bevölkerungsfonds
der vereinten nationen gestärkt das war
uns freien demokraten ein besonderes
anliegen nicht zuletzt weil wir wie auch
im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart vereinbart die multilaterale
zusammenarbeit weiter stärken wollen das
gilt auch für die global financing
facility über die wir die gesundheit von
kindern und jugendlichen auch in diesem
jahr wieder mehr fördern durch die
erhöhung des titels multilaterale hilfen
zum weltweiten schutz der umwelt der
biodiversität und des klimas leistet
deutschland einen im internationalen
vergleich herausragenden beitrag zum
klimaschutz
hier wird deutlich dass deutschland mit
seinem engagement auf der nationalen
ebene führungsstark und zuverlässig ist
vor der bundestagswahl haben wir freien
demokraten gesagt nie gab es mehr zu tun
und das gilt für kaum einen politischen
bereich so sehr wie für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
deswegen haben wir auch in zeiten in
denen nicht nur russland
desinformationen als waffe einsetzt die
mittel für den zugang zu informationen
und die medienförderung und zwei
millionen euro erhöht
insbesondere in folge so kleine kriegs
ist die situation in dem von
nahrungsmittelknappheit betroffenen
ländern überaus schwierig wird
beobachten dass allen voran china stark
daran arbeitet sein einfluss in afrika
wo entwicklungsprojekte auszudehnen
gleichzeitig wird uns heutzutage einen
besuch an der tankstelle auf drastische
weise vor augen wie abhängig deutschland
wie abhängig europa von einigen wenigen
importeure fossiler brennstoffe ist
beide probleme lassen sich auch mit
einer klugen ganzheitlich gedachten
entwicklungszusammenarbeit an denen
schauen wir ein paar jahre die zukunft
für eine brennende sonne heute das leben
schwierig macht kann künftig erneuerbare
energie erzeugt werden so können
praktisch alle unsere partnerländer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit an globalen
nachhaltigen wertschöpfungsketten
teilhaben das kann auch einen
erheblichen beitrag dazu leisten dem
origami spielt politisch geprägten
energiemarkt dezentral und
marktorientiert neu aufzustellen und
diese zukunftsvorstellungen sollten sich
zunehmend jetzt auch in unseren
entwicklungs haushalten finden und herr
kollege körper
ich würde das immer sehr gerne was sie
zu diesem thema sagen aber muss immer
wieder feststellen in ihren haushalten
stand das auch noch nicht drin aber wir
werden jetzt mit diesen haushalten die
nächsten haushalten damit anfangen und
da freue ich mich über ihre kooperation
vielen dank herr kollege maßmann der
kollege thomas rachel cdu csu halten
sehr geehrter präsident liebe kollegen
kollegen die cdu csu fraktion nimmt ihre
kontrollfunktion als größte
oppositionsfraktion sehr ernst sie ist
kritisch aber konstruktiv
zusammen mit der zivilgesellschaft haben
wir christdemokraten die ursprünglich
geplanten massiven kürzungen des
haushalts des bundesministeriums für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung kritisiert gleichzeitig aber
konstruktive änderungsanträge im
zuständigen fachausschuss gestellt als
opposition begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
dass die bundesregierung nun doch
zusätzliche mittel für das bmz vorsieht
hier hat der druck von opposition und
zivilgesellschaft ganz offensichtlich
gewirkt
ebenso positiv hervorheben möchte ich
die erweiterung der bmz partnerländer
und bolivien
lateinamerika hat größere aufmerksamkeit
verdient denn leider verschärfen sich
die sozialen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen krisen auf diesem kontinent
hier ist ein paradigmenwechsel dringend
geboten dennoch möchte ich gerne drei
bereiche herausgreifen die uns in der
entwicklungspolitik der bundesregierung
sorge bereiten in diesem jahr feiern wir
zurecht 60 jahre partnerschaft in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit mit den
beiden großen kirchen das hilfswerk der
evangelischen kirche brot für die welt
und dass der katholischen kirche
misereor leisten einen unverzichtbaren
beitrag in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
gerade durch die starke verankerung der
kirchen in den zivilgesellschaften
sowohl in deutschland wie auch in
unseren partnerländern erzielen die
kirchlichen hilfswerke eine ganz
beachtliche reichweite und akzeptanz für
die hilfsprojekte
gerade in den ländern in denen die
staatliche zusammenarbeit an ihre
grenzen stößt sind die kirchen weiterhin
aktiv doch statt diese vertrauensvolle
partnerschaft zwischen staat und kirchen
auszubauen kürzt die bundesregierung
trotz aufstockung im ergänzungs haus hat
unterm strich die barmittel für die
entwicklungsvorhaben der kirchen dies
wird der wichtigen arbeit der
kirchlichen hilfswerke nicht gerecht und
ist ein falsches signal der
bundesregierung
kommen wir zum themenfeld der bildung
das wmc in der bundesregierung unter
angela merkel das ziel formuliert 25
prozent der entwicklungspolitischen
ausgaben in bildung und berufliche
bildung zu investieren
ich glaube das ist auch dringend
notwendig wir erleben gerade ausgelöst
durch die korona pandemie eine
historisch beispiellose bildungskrise
weltweit
schulschließungen haben alle lern
gewinne der letzten 20 jahre zunichte
gemacht wegen der korona pandemie werden
zusätzliche 10 millionen mädchen den
zugang zu bildung dauerhaft verlieren
das ist eine echte katastrophe
denn bildung leistet einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag um armut zu reduzieren
und chancengleichheit zu ermöglichen wo
bleibt das klare ziel von
bundesministerin schulze 25 prozent der
entwicklungspolitischen gesamtausgaben
in bildung zu investieren frage ich hier
ganz deutlich
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir christdemokraten begrüßen die mitte
erhöhung im bereich der welternährung
aber die politik der bundesregierung
bleibt hier vollkommen widersprüchlich
putin nutzt mit seinem angriff auf die
ukraine hunger als waffe während andere
europäische staaten ihre brachflächen zb
für brotweizen freigeben verweigert dies
die deutsche bundesregierung durch diese
fehlentscheidung der bundesregierung
können hier in deutschland rund 800.000
tonnen weizen im jahr nicht geerntet
werden damit könnten und drei millionen
hungernde menschen ernährt werden die
bundesregierung muss diese falsche
entscheidung korrigieren
wir fordern deshalb die bundesregierung
auf erstens bekennen sie sich zum ziel
25 prozent der entwicklungspolitischen
ausgaben in bildung zu investieren
zweitens bauen sie die wichtige
zusammenarbeit mit den kirchlichen
hilfswerken weiter aus und kürze sie
nicht und drittens lassen sie die
deutschen landwirte auch die
brachflächen für den weizenanbau nutzen
denn wir wollen den hungernden menschen
helfen herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr gelegen war das für die
unionsfraktionen und jetzt hat noch mal
eine abgeordnete der sozialdemokraten
hier das wort matthias sammer wird das
seien sie sitzt im ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung
die beratung zum haushalt des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung für
dieses jahr haben es mal wieder gezeigt
das parlament bestimmt den haushalt
aufgrund der vielfältigen krisen denen
wir rund um den globus begegnen müssen
hätte es nun wirklich welt fremd gewirkt
wenn der haushalt des bmz wie im ersten
entwurf vorgesehen um 1 6 milliarden
euro gekürzt worden wäre daher möchte
ich mich auch noch mal bei allen
bedanken
die sich in den verhandlungen zum
haushalt für ein gut ausgestattetes bmz
eingesetzt haben
wir sehen dass die korona könnte mir
auch in den ländern des globalen südens
noch immer nicht vorbei ist und wir
wissen doch alle dass die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen der
pandemie in den partnerländern viel
schlimmer sind als die pandemie selbst
die armut steigt rasant die zahl der
hungernden menschen nimmt zu etliche
erfolge der zusammenarbeit der letzten
jahre sind durch die folgen der pandemie
weggewischt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
ja nicht was heute für den tag ist heute
ist der internationale kindertag ein tag
der in meiner heimatstadt leipzig eine
hohe bedeutung hat ein tag an dem die
ganze stadt kinder ins zentrum der
aufmerksamkeit nimmt ich finde wir
sollten das alles alle viel öfter tun
die globale situation aufgrund der
korona pandemie sieht vielerorts so aus
kinder leiden hunger gehen nicht mehr
zur schule und arbeiten stattdessen im
informellen sektor wir dürfen aber nicht
zulassen dass es zu einer ganzen
verlorenen generation kommt deshalb
freue ich mich sehr dass wir in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit einen fokus
auf bildungsförderung leben aus dem
ergänzungs haushalt konnten wir etwa
education kerner 14 millionen euro
zusätzlich geben damit sind wir bei
diesem titel bei insgesamt 60 millionen
euro angekommen wir sagen
entwicklungspolitik muss kinder schützen
und stärken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
länder des globalen südens erleiden
schwerwiegende folgen durch den
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
das hat nicht nur unmittelbare
auswirkungen vor ort sondern bringt
weitreichende folgen für die ganze welt
mit sich besonders im bereich der
nahrungsmittelproduktion und dem
transport wir reden hier nicht mehr von
einer ernährungskrise sondern von einer
echten hungersnot in der ganzen region
steigen die brotpreise rasant im libanon
haben sie sich vervierfacht in ägypten
verdoppelt der brotpreis ist ein
politischer preis gerade angesichts der
hohen staatsverschuldung in afrika
sitzen eine deshalb auf einem pulverfass
und wir wissen alle nicht wie lange die
lunte noch ist
ich bin svenja schulze sehr dankbar dass
sie im zuge des deutschen g7 vorsitzes
ein neues bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit ins leben gerufen
hat diese aufgabe die ganz klar beim bmz
und ist dort auch genau richtig
aufgehoben und dort brauchen wir auch
weiterhin die nötigen finanziellen
mittel
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wie
gesagt die aufgabe der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die aufgaben
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit sind
nicht kleiner sondern größer geworden
laut nun hat er sind weltweit erstmals
mehr als 100 millionen menschen auf der
flucht diese enorme zahl an finden
menschen heißt für uns auch wir müssen
für die menschen vor ort echte
perspektiven schaffen denn über die
hälfte der 100 millionen fliehenden
menschen sind binnenvertriebene um den
fluchtursachen zu begegnen müssen wir
präventiv handeln ein euro vor ort für
die entwicklung auszugeben um
wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche
perspektiven zu schaffen
ist ein bruchteil dessen was es kostet
menschen auf der flucht zu versorgen
denn eine weitere zahl für mich in dem
zusammenhang wirklich krass
durchschnittlich sind fliegende menschen
20 jahre lang auf der flucht 20 jahre
ihres lebens
nichts ist der stabilisierende als
hungernde menschen das sollten wir uns
immer vor augen führen natürlich können
wir die bundeslehrer nato oder
un-truppen in krisenregionen schicken
aber es geht auch einfacher und auch
nachhaltiger wir brauchen eine ehrliche
wirksame und für alle gewinnbringende
zusammenarbeit mit den partnerländern
dabei sprechen wir von einer
zusammenarbeit auf augenhöhe
ich denke wir müssen bald ein neues
kapitel der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
arbeit aufschlagen und eine neue
souveränität für die partnerländer
anstreben werden die variabilität
gewinnt kann auf der weltbühne selbst
und eine gleichberechtigte
zusammenarbeit einfordern und auch
erreichen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie haben
in den haushalt viel geld in die hand
genommen und dazu beigetragen dass der
wiederaufbau der ukraine auch vom bmz
unterstützt werden kann es ist eine
kernaufgabe dieses ministeriums
nachhaltige strukturen und damit
stabilität aufzubauen kein haus kann das
besser als das bmz mit seiner langen
erfahrung und seinem kompetenten
mitarbeiter in an dieser stelle meinen
ganz herzlichen dank an sie alle ich bin
übrigens auch ganz begeistert dass
svenja schulze im bmz eine feministische
entwicklungspolitik zum schwerpunkt
macht und das spiegelt sich auch im
haushalt wieder frauen und mädchen
machen die hälfte der bevölkerung aus
diese hälfte bei politischen
entscheidungen einzubinden und ihr eine
stimme zu geben sollte eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein wenn frauen
die gleiche entscheidungsmacht haben die
männer gibt es einen festeren
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt vielfach
sind es frauen die lokale expertinnen
sind oder fachwissen aus ihren berufen
mitbringen und doch bleiben sie bei
wesentlichen entscheidungen oft außen
vor und werden eben nicht mit einbezogen
und das zu ändern müssen wir bei allen
entwicklungspolitischen vorhaben eine
gender perspektive integrieren
und auf der fokus auf frauenrechte ist
mir wichtig frauenrechte sind das recht
jeder frau auf allgemeine menschenrechte
die freiheit und unabhängigkeit von
frauen ist der gradmesser einer freien
gesellschaft für alle das werden wir
auch im ausschuss verbittert
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung in meinem blick behalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist
friedensarbeit was wird uns denn in
diesen tagen bewusster als die bedeutung
von frieden freiheit und sicherheit
entwicklungszusammenarbeit schafft
stabilität auf beiden seiten unsere
gezielte unterstützung der
zivilgesellschaft in den partnerländern
sorgt für die notwendige verankerung von
nachhaltigen veränderungen ich möchte
daher denjenigen die sich schon jetzt
mit denen mit erarbeitung des haushalts
für 23 befassen mitgeben dass er auch in
zukunft eine gut ausgestattete
entwicklungszusammenarbeit brauchen die
dem vernetzten sicherheitsgedanken und
unserem koalitionsvorhaben der 11
regelungen gerecht wird denn nach dem
haushalt ist vor ihm aushalten
ein problem sagt matthias dahmer hierfür
die spd tatsächlich der haushalts 2023
muss ja in diesem jahr beraten
werden
jetzt hören wir kathrin henneberger für
die grünen und sie sehen wenn du so ein
vorschaubild wir erwarten auch noch eine
pressekonferenz mit bundeskanzler scholz
und seinem kroatischen amtskollegen das
wollen wir ihnen natürlich zeigen
[Musik]
nicht
sein wir jetzt wenn ihr wieder ernsthaft
seien wir ehrlich
internationale klimapolitik von
industriestaaten in den letzten
jahrzehnten
die waren besonders geprägt von schönen
worten aber nicht durch effektive taten
noch immer steigen die emissionen noch
immer sind wir auf einem weg in eine
welt vier bis sechs grad heißer also
genug der schönen worte die emissionen
müssen sinken und die finanzen für klima
und biodiversitätsschutz die müssen
steigen und nach harten ring in den
letzten monaten lässt sich nun sagen
dank grüner verhandlungen haben wir es
in diesem jahr geschafft dass die
gekürzten mittel für internationale
klima finanzen wieder erhöht wurden und
das ist ein großer erfolg und da danke
ich ganz herzlich den verhandeln
wichtig
wichtig waren es hierbei auch darauf zu
achten dass titel erhöht wurden die
indigenen gemeinden und die am stärksten
betroffenen regionen zugute kommen sowie
für weitere projekte und für klima
risikoversicherung bereit stehen gelder
für internationale klimafinanzierung
wir sind verteilt in den
unterschiedlichen ministerien im bmw k
und im auswärtigen und deswegen haben
wir darauf geachtet dass auch dort die
finanzen erhöht worden sind und auch das
wurde erreicht noch das ist ein großer
erfolg
aber natürlich im angesicht der
grausamen realität der klimakrise wissen
wir das kann nur ein anfang sein
damit deutschland seinen fairen anteil
ein held ein internationalen klima
finanzen brauchen wir erst eine erhöhung
auf 6 milliarden und dann eine erhöhung
auf acht bis zehn milliarden jährlich
dafür braucht es eine klare zusage von
seiten des auch des bundesministeriums
für finanzen das im kommenden haushalt
für 2023 die mitte für das bmz nicht
weiter gekürzt werden sondern wieder
deutlich aufwachsen
hinzu kommen in diesem jahr natürlich
auch finanzen für los und damage für
verlust und schäden durch die klimakrise
hier haben wir eine besondere globale
verantwortung vor der wir uns mit blick
auf die nächste un-klimakonferenz in
ägypten auch nicht drücken dürfen hier
werden wir verantwortung für
klimagerechtigkeit übernehmen
die auswirkung einer ungebremsten
klimakrise können wir eigentlich gar
nicht beziffern und deshalb brauchen wir
eine echte klima finanzpolitik von
anfang an dafür müssen auch endlich
subventionen für fossile der
vergangenheit an und dafür werden wir
arbeiten vielen dank
grüne reden henneberger war das ja der
bundestag hat sozusagen fast bergfest
bei den haushaltsberatungen der zweite
tag hier der geht so ganz langsam dem
ende zu einige redner haben wir noch zu
dem letzten einzelplan heute zwei tage
übrigens liegen noch vor uns das schon
mal als vorausschauend damen und herren
entwicklungszusammenarbeit was bringt
denn das eigentlich es bringt viel wenn
wir es richtig machen und es bringt viel
für die menschen im globalen süden und
die gesamte menschheit es bringt aber
auch für uns selbst die entwicklung
zusammen heute ist eine sehr sehr große
aufgabe und deshalb wird es vielen
menschen und bürger in unserem land
schwer daran zu glauben oder auch
erfolge zu sehen aber es lohnt sich
wirklich und die erfolge der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit können sich
sehen lassen
der haushalt 20 22 hat im ersten entwurf
nur 10,8 milliarden gehabt jetzt sind es
über 13 milliarden das ist eine
wohltuende erhöhung um unsere
internationalen versprechen einzulösen
gegenüber den organisationen wie den
vereinten nationen oder zb der
bildungsinitiative global partnership
for education das ist ganz ganz wichtig
weil verlässlichkeit in der politik ist
ein ganz ganz wichtiges und hohes gut
für akzeptanz und ansehen unserer
bundesrepublik
wir haben auch mehr gelder
zusammengestellt in dem haushalt jetzt
für frauen familienplanung für
gesundheit für alles dies sind die
mittel noch mal erhöht worden und die
fdp hat da durchaus auch ihren anteil
gehabt
noch mehr freut mich natürlich dass wir
auch mehr geld haben für wald und klima
schutz für biodiversität auch das dient
uns selbst wenn wir dann diese
genetischen ressourcen erhalten und auch
unser klima sich nicht weiter
verschlechtert wenn wir dort die welt da
heißt es gut so ampel weiter so ampel
und die entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist
wichtiger denn je das haben viele noch
nicht so ganz verstanden wir haben eine
zeitenwende und deshalb ist es
hervorragend dass kanzler olaf scholz
nach afrika gefahren ist in die
entwicklungsländer in diesen
krisenzeiten das war ein ganz ganz
großes zeichen und wir müssen uns ja
überlegen wie soll's denn die sollen
denn diese länder mit der jetzigen krise
fertig werden ohne unsere hilfe die
hungerkrise die steigenden
lebensmittelpreise
das können diese armen ländern nicht
alleine arbeiten und deshalb ist es an
uns jetzt zu helfen bei uns gab es auch
hungersnöte nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
und uns wurde auch geholfen wem sind die
care pakete nicht bekannt wem sind die
rosinenbomber über berlin nicht bekannt
und jetzt ist es an uns dies auch
zurückzugeben an diejenigen ländern die
hungern werden und das haben wir in
diesem haushalt auch abgebildet und
deshalb ist dieser haushalt ein guter
und deshalb werden wir ihn auch
unterstützen und wir werden auch dafür
sorgen dass wir in zukunft in diesem
haushalt genügend geld haben die krisen
dieser welt zu meistern zumindest
unseren deutschen anteil dazu leisten
können herzlichen dank deshalb hofft man
war das für die fdp und das ist nicht
sehr spekulativ
wenn man annimmt dass dieser einzelplan
die mehrheit der ampel koalition finden
wird hier in der zweiten beratung die
wichtige abstimmung am freitag wenn alle
einzelpläne gelesen sind in zweiter
beratung und abgestimmt dann das ganze
haushalt besetzt mit allen
haushaltsplänen das werden sie natürlich
auch bei uns verfolgen aber wir haben ja
noch zwei tage haushaltsberatungen ein
kürzere vorausblick auf morgen mit den
interessanten etats gesundheit
wirtschaft und klimaschutz und morgen
früh startet hier der bundestag mit dem
etat zu innen- und heimat ab 8.45 sind
wir dann wieder live für sie im
bundestag für den moment darf ich mich
hier verabschieden und gebe zu meinem
kollegen hans werner fittkau nachbarn
oppositionsarbeit ist wichtig kritik der
zivilgesellschaft ist wichtig und es hat
ja auch früchte getragen und
zum positiven zuerst wir begrüßen die
vorgenommenen erhöhung bei den titeln
die für die bewältigung der pandemie und
der kriegsfolgen wichtig sind das
betrifft sowohl die maßnahmen in der
ukraine
das in den umliegenden
flüchtlingsaufnahme ländern wie auch für
die internationale ernährungssicherung
und ganz besonders zu begrüßen ist die
deutliche steigerung der
verpflichtungsermächtigung beim globalen
fonds zur bekämpfung von aids
tuberkulose und malaria auf 1,2
milliarden euro
damit kann deutschland einen
angemessenen beitrag bei der
wiederauffüllungskonferenz im herbst zu
sagen das wird auch andere geber
motivieren ihren beitrag zu steigern und
wenn mich jetzt hier auf die reaktionen
von der afg schau die haben schon das
vorgänger ministeriums vorgenommen
ministerium kritisiert wenn es um
projekte zur förderung von frauen und
mädchen gingen zum beispiel im bereich
der landwirtschaft bildung und
gesundheit deswegen brauchen wir darauf
auch keinen wert legen aber zur wahrheit
gehört auch wenn man heidemarie
wieczorek zeul erwähnt dann hatte hier
unter dem damaligen spd bundeskanzler
gerhard schröder sehr gelitten und drei
kreuze gemacht als ihre arbeit unter
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel cdu
endlich anerkennung gefunden hat das
gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu
aber kommen wir zurück zu kritisieren
ist dass der titel für die
zusammenarbeit mit der wirtschaft zurück
geht und nur mit der privatwirtschaft
werden nachhaltige arbeitsplätze auch in
entwicklungsländern geschaffen und
leider geschätzte kolleginnen und
kollegen von der fdp wird der titel der
dies unterstützt nicht gestärkt der
rückgang der verpflichtungsermächtigung
im bereich der sogenannten
strukturierten fonds von 210 millionen
euro auf 100 euro beweist vielmehr dass
man diesem instrument in zukunft
offenbar keine bedeutung mehr beimisst
dabei stellt sich für mich und für uns
dann die frage welche strategie sie frau
ministerin gegenüber chinesischen
investitionen in entwicklungsländern
verfolgen denn privatwirtschaftliche
investitionen und werte zu verbinden ist
eine zentrale antwort auf die frage der
diversifizierung von märkten und die
bundesregierung ist hier leider ganz
blass und leider sehr schlecht
aufgestellt
unzureichend bleibt auch die
mittelausstattung für die zukunft wenn
der finanzplan wie auch die
verpflichtungsermächtigungen nicht
angepasst werden steht das bmz ab 2023
vor dem gleichen problem wie zu beginn
dieses jahres es brauche aber klarheit
durch anpassung des finanzplans darauf
zu hoffen dass die probleme von selbst
verschwinden und schon keine weiteren
beiträge erforderlich sein werden ist
einfach nicht genug und frau ministerin
an der zukünftigen finanzplanung können
sie beweisen ob sie ihren worten auch
taten folgen lassen bislang sieht es
nicht danach aus
wunderschön vielen dank herr kollege
noch so schön sagen sie fertig
abschließend frau ministerin und herr
präsident wir
und ich ganz persönlich begrüßen ihren
willen die ukraine beim wiederaufbau zu
unterstützen und ihre reise ins
kriegsgebiet und die cdu csu fraktion
würde das im gegensatz zum bundeskanzler
auch nicht als rein raus fototermin
bezeichnen allerdings möchte ich ihnen
auf diesem weg noch etwas mitgeben wenn
sie das nächste mal an der
kabinettssitzung teilnehmen wenden sie
sich bitte an ihren parteikollegen olaf
scholz bitte schauen sie im tief in die
augen und berichten von ihren eindrücken
aus der ukraine
vielleicht besteht dadurch die chance
dass er erstens selbst nach kiew reift
und zweitens die ukraine endlich
angemessen aus deutschland unterstützung
erhält denn es liegt auch in unserer
verantwortung dass die ukraine diesen
krieg gewinnen wird herzlichen dank
jetzt aber vielen dank herr kollege cpj
letzte redner in dieser debatte ist die
kollegin susanne menge wird es 90 liegen
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
zeitenwende ist auch verknüpft mit dem
blick auf alle frauen die in kriegen und
gewaltherrschaft die sozialen gefüge
innerhalb einer gesellschaft
aufrechterhalten auch im bunker mit
kindern ohne wasser stets improvisierend
und das überleben sichern es geht beim
erweiterten sicherung sicherheitsbegriff
in der tat um sehr viel mehr als die
abwesenheit von krieg im zentrum unseres
handelns und unserer entscheidung darf
dabei nicht nur die sicherheit von
staaten stehen priorität hat menschliche
sicherheit gesundheit bildung sicherung
von ernährung und so weiter
feministische entwicklungspolitik ist
die minister außenpolitik ist
feministische infrastrukturpolitik ist
feministische gesellschaftspolitik und
bedeutet nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als unsere zumeist von männern
dominierte welt und ihre verhältnisse
kritisch zu reflektieren und auch zu
verändern der große entwurf ist immer
noch eine gerechte welt in der wir in
frieden miteinander leben können frauen
wollen diese welt mitgestalten wollen
teilhaben und sollen teilhaben an
entscheidungsfindung und den dialog zum
frieden mit führen aber mädchen frauen
für ihre menschenkinder people of colour
und menschen mit behinderung sind
überall auf unserer welt strukturell
benachteiligt sie werden mehrfach auf
unterschiedliche art und weise
diskriminiert gleichzeitig erleben wir
aber weltweit starke
veränderungsprozesse die zumeist von
jungen frauen angeführt werden und die
gewinn bringt in gesellschaftliche
prozesse eingreifen menschen machen
politik und menschen gestalten systeme
es liegt folglich an uns menschen global
die menschenrechte durchzusetzen und
allen menschen ihr recht auf
selbstbestimmung zu gewähren und das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen geht nur
gemeinsam mit uns frauen dieser haushalt
stellt einen ersten schritt in die
richtige richtung da wir unterstützen in
diesem jahr mit insgesamt 18 millionen
euro das ist eine verdoppelung des
ansatzes des ehemaligen
entwicklungsministers müller 25
millionen euro fließen wenn die global
financing facility für frauen kinder und
jugendlichen auch die finanzierung für
das kommende jahr ist gesichert die
letzte bundesregierung hatte im
vergleich dazu übrigens die streichung
des anteils vorgesehen laut den
aktuellen zahlen liegen wir bei
lächerlichen 2,3 prozent aller
öffentlich geförderten
entwicklungspolitischen sowie
außenpolitischen projekte und programme
die der geschlechter die die
geschlechtergerechtigkeit zum hauptziel
haben unser ziel ist ein stetiger
anstieg dieser mittel den der über einen
maßgaben des schluss für das bmz
gesichert haben der vorgänger von
ministerin schulze hatte dafür volle
acht jahre zeit um das genau zu tun
hatte aber nicht das bmz braucht
ressourcen zur aufstellung der gender
kompetenzen bis zur übernahme unserer
entwicklungsministerin hatte das bmz
noch nicht einmal ein eigenes gender
referat auch das wird nun endlich
aufgebaut mittelfristig brauchen wir
gender kompetenzen in jeder abteilung
des bmz und das sage ich selbst übrigens
auch in jedem ministerium
gesellschaftliche veränderungen in
politische prozesse einzubinden und
entsprechend zu handeln sind nach 16
jahren stillstands politik wahrlich nach
nur einem halben jahr schwerlich möglich
der entwicklungspolitische haushalt 22
macht aber deutlich dass wir diese
aufgabe jetzt endlich mit progressivem
schwung anfangen ich danke fürs zuhören
und wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
vielen dank kolleginnen damit
schließlich die aussprache
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 23 bundesministerin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung in der ausschuss fassung wer
stimmt dafür
koalitionsfraktionen der stimmt dagegen
die gesamte opposition damit ist
einzelplan 23 in der ausweisung
angenommen wir sind da wir am schluss
die unsere heutigen tagesordnung ich
wünsche ihnen allen einen wunderschönen
abend am besten den gastronomischen
betrieben dieses dieser stadt ich berufe
die nächste sitzung des deutschen
bundestages ein auf morgen donnerstag
den zweiten juli 2022 9 uhr die sitzung
ist beschlossen